91 you give me dead eyes it's me
maxi-pad max Kessler seen you in forever
you still work at save and pay
supermarket no no I manage the bank it's
inside of saving pay can you tell me
where I can find a kitty liver
it's aisle two just wish I could start
from scratch
let maxi pad soak up your pain make the
smoke it right here that's right
hey mr. sleepyhead
why am I tied up they want you to freak
out when you came to you think time you
do beds not gonna freak me out charlie I
made your wish come true I faked our
deaths you did what
Charlie you tried Oh know what else I
think you said it all we both needed a
fresh start you get a brand-new life I
just borrowed two dead bodies
you were officially dr. Ronald P Fishman
hey you asleep it writer and fishermen
have returned from the dead is so
gentlemen have taken over their
identities what the [ __ ] is this
these guys they're involved with
something [ __ ] shame right O&L dr.
Ronald Fishman's why what's the plan
what the [ __ ] let me just make sure
you're all right how many ass all
drivers can you see right now one right
on the money there's some people to
think I'm your husband they're trying to
kill us why do they think you're Ronnie
well we've got an impersonator he's also
wearing his clothes like a [ __ ]
weirdo we do want you buckle up
what was so terrible about you like that
what a whole new one the kind of wasn't
my choice
I think there's some girl spying on us
Oh who's this sexy [ __ ] on his mother
not you MA
madam Hey
she's trusted tiny oh I leave miss
Nakata Stoffer when Otto isn't often
shot light in a bank in